[Música]
empezamos ahora revista de prensa en
directo américa de france 24 ya rosa
pérez en más de eu conmigo en el estudio
para continuar lo que estábamos hablando
con laurel de estos ataques de
terroristas a estos atentados que
sacudieron la capital francesa el pasado
13 de noviembre del año 2015 rosa
empezamos con las portadas de hoy a la
espera también de esta sentencia de este
veredicto del juicio histórico como le
estábamos hablando con la rosa buenos
días raúl exactamente no a la espera de
la que va a ser la sentencia de este
juicio histórico como nos contaba lea un
poco la prensa francesa titulada de las
siguientes formas por un lado liberación
dice la humanidad ya ha ganado la cual
dice la gran familia de las víctimas y
es algo que relatan tanto los
supervivientes como los familiares de
víctimas que murieron en estos ataques y
en los estrechos lazos que se han creado
pues entre pues las personas que han
formado la parte civil entre abogados
entre prensa por otro lado le parisien
pues señalan las lecciones de un proceso
histórico vamos a ver como reacción a la
prensa francesa a la que va a ser la
sentencia que vamos a conocer en unas
horas y que pueden seguir aquí en
directo en france 24 pero si te parece
raúl vamos a hacer pues una mirada
retrospectiva de cómo la prensa tituló
al día siguiente de estos atentados y
empezamos entonces por los medios
estadounidenses como amanecieron el día
después de estos atentados del 3 de
noviembre 2015 es decir el 14 de
noviembre de ese año es muy interesante
no hacer este ejercicio porque mirar la
prensa de ese día inevitablemente pues
le traslada a uno a la conmoción lo que
se vivía en ese momento por un lado el
new york times dice los ataques
terroristas en parís matan a más de 100
personas y esta es una de las
características que vamos a encontrar en
los titulares de toda la prensa que
vamos a comentar y es este baile de
cifras porque sobre todo en europa se
cerraban las rotativas cuando todavía no
estaba claro el número de víctimas
mortales y en los periódicos del
continente americano vemos que también
hay variaciones en todo caso en new york
times dice
y horror hacen eco en la ciudad una vez
más y es que tal y como nos comentaba
lea pues ese año 2015 había estado
marcado por distintos atentados y quizás
antes de este del 13 de noviembre en la
más impactante fue el de charlie hebdo
por otro lado el 'new york times'
destaquemos estas tres imágenes no de
los distintos puntos donde pues tuvieron
lugar estos atentados y la crónica de
esa noche empieza en esta portada en el
stade france como decía lea donde jugaba
la selección francesa contra la alemana
y dice la noche era tranquila el
presidente françois hollande miraba el
partido con la afición mientras los
jugadores franceses llevaban el balón
más allá del mediocampo luego sonó el
agudo e inconfundible estruendo de una
explosión ensordeciendo los gritos los
gritos de la multitud pasó un momento de
estupefacción los jugadores y los
espectadores parecían confundidos y de
repente la horrible comprensión barrió
el estadio el terror por segunda vez
este año golpeado bien pues una
estupefacción un shock que sin duda
también sintieron las personas que pues
simplemente habían salido un viernes por
la noche a tomar algo oa un concierto
como fue el caso de las víctimas del
bataclán que fue pues el escenario donde
ocurrió la mayor masacre y por otro lado
el times dice parís bajo asedio y con la
misma imagen de personas rescatadas de
la bataclana en el washington post dice
asalto en parís más de 140 asesinados lo
que decíamos de las cifras no finalmente
pues fueron menos y también francia
refuerza los controles fronterizos y es
que estos uno de los grandes puntos que
causó polémica no este cierre de
fronteras que pues ya tuvo lugar en ese
momento y que se extendió durante años y
pues que distintas organizaciones a
criticaron que sirvió para controlar la
migración clandestina más que pues
posibles terroristas por otro lado el
wall street journal dice masacre en
parís y es según un artículo de la
revista slate de francia que vamos a
comentar en seguida el wall street
journal decidió usar la foto que vamos a
ver a continuación por qué según la jefa
de fotografía de este periódico ella
sola evoca la magnitud del ataque y la
desolación posterior y decidieron puedes
descartar las imágenes digamos más
explícitas con más digamos pues víctimas
en primer plano y utilizar esta imagen
pues no tan pues que habrá por si sola
triste rosa impactante imagen en américa
latina que encontramos el correio
braziliense terror sangra el corazón de
parís el tiempo de colombia terror en
parís la jornada de méxico también
terror en parís el comercio de perú
masacre en parís y es que a veces pues
faltan las palabras no y sólo uno pues
se le ocurren estas pues terror masacre
por otro lado la tercera de chile al
menos 118 muertos tras una cadena de
atentados en europa rápidamente rosa the
times masacre en parís otra vez del país
decenas de muertos en una cadena de
atentados en parís ´corriere della sera´
la guerra en país libération en
liberación a queríamos destacar
precisamente gracias a este artículo de
slate lo hemos sabido también que en un
primer momento este periódico francés
usar una imagen donde se veía a una
víctima aquí esta que estamos viendo no
cubierta ya con unos paños pero después
decidió digamos usar esta imagen sin
cambiar el titulares de carnage no esta
masacre decidió usar una imagen de
rescatados del bataclán y esta es la
portada del domingo para la que
evidentemente no pues hace falta más
palabras también le parecían
excepcionalmente público dos ediciones
el 14 de noviembre el día después de
estos atentados la primera de con el
titular esta vez es la guerra y la
segunda simplemente parís 13 de
noviembre de 2015 pues una día que pues
queda marcado en la historia así de rosa
pues evidentemente se nos queda por
fuera muchísima información muchísimos
periódicos pero bueno ahí rescatamos
como los más importantes los más
destacados de casi todas las regiones
del planeta gracias rosa como siempre
por toda la información nosotros
continuamos de esto es directo américa